Aaron Swartz was nothing short of a child
prodigy.
At the age of 14, he helped create RSS, a
popular tool for keeping up with the latest
news and blog posts before the advent of social
media.
He formed a company that merged with Reddit
and is credited with making Reddit one of
the most popular sites on the internet.
Yet that’s not what he was known for.
He was known for his internet activism, which
led to the ultimate tragedy.
I couldn’t wait until the whole world was
on the internet and I never had to call anybody
again.
The computer was his favorite toy growing
up in a wealthy suburb of Chicago.
His father worked in the tech industry, so
computers were always a part of his life.
They were also a distraction from the serious
bowel condition that often crippled him with
stomach pain.
As a result, he only ate bland food like rice
and pasta.
He hated fruits and veggies.
Aaron thought the internet was magical.
One of the exciting things about Wikipedia
is that it doesn’t just have an article
on the 100 most popular things, or the thousand
most popular things.
You can pick the most obscure subject on the
world and there’s an article about it.
Because for everything there’s someone who
cares a great deal about it.
And that’s what television, that’s what
radio doesn’t provide, but the internet
does.
Yet he also felt there were barriers that
limited the ability of people to share and
distribute knowledge freely, like strict copyright
laws.
We have the right as American citizens to
have this sort of free and open communication
to share what we think, what we feel, what
we’ve created.
I think that’s a huge part of our culture.
This notion that we’ve become a permission-asking
society that every time you do something you
have to ask permission.
That’s basically against the freedom culture
we have here.
That’s the opposite of a free country.
Aaron believed no one should be deprived of
information and sought to break down these
barriers.
He dropped out of Stanford after a year to
pursue his interest in internet freedom.
In 2008, he wrote this manifesto:
“Information is power.
But like all power, there are those who want
to keep it for themselves.
The world’s entire scientific and cultural
heritage, published over centuries in books
and journals, is increasingly being digitized
and locked up by a handful of private corporations.
We need to take information, wherever it is
stored, make our copies and share them with
the world.”
That year, he took on the U.S. government’s
online court records system, PACER, which
stores information about cases, court filings,
and docket details.
He was frustrated that PACER charged for documents
-- 8 cents per page at the time – 10 cents
today.
Aaron believed the documents should be free
because they were produced at the taxpayer’s
expense.
So he set out to republish these documents
on a public website for anyone to access.
He visited one of the few public libraries
that did allow free downloads of PACER documents
and installed code he'd written to request
a new document every three seconds.
This way, he got his hands on nearly 20 million
pages of documents - or around 20% of the
database, and uploaded the files to Amazon’s
cloud computing service.
When the court system’s IT department realized
something was up, the FBI got involved, and
contacted Amazon, which provided his name,
phone number, and address as their user agreement
allows them to do so at the government’s
request.
Aaron recalled in an interview, “I had this
vision of the feds crashing down the door,
taking everything away.”
The feds investigated but didn’t prosecute
him.
Two years later, it would be a different story…when
authorities say he hacked the servers at MIT
to steal millions of files from a digital
library.
In September 2010, federal authorities say
Aaron broke into MIT’s computer network
by accessing a restricted utility closet on
campus in the basement of Building 16, which
housed network equipment and cabling.
The room was reportedly left unlocked.
He hardwired his laptop into the network and
hid it under a cardboard box.
The laptop ran a script called “keepgrabbing.py”
which set it to automatically download academic
journals from the digital library JSTOR.
Aaron used a guest account to access JSTOR.
At the time, any computer connected to MIT’s
open wireless network could access the digital
library.
Many institutions pay a lot of money so their
students can subscribe for free.
Otherwise, plans for individuals cost $19.50
a month for just 10 PDF downloads.
He created the fake guest identity “Gary
Host” which prompted the computer network
to identify his computer as “ghost” when
shortened - an apparent reference to its ability
to disappear.
Although Aaron used a legitimate guest account,
he violated JSTOR’s terms of use by using
an automated program to access articles.
At one point, he downloaded about 700 articles
a minute!
Between September 2010 to January 2011, he
downloaded nearly 5 million articles or 80%
of JSTOR’s database, valued at hundreds
of thousands of dollars.
A federal indictment claims he intended to
upload all of the documents to a peer-to-peer
file-sharing site where anyone could access
them for free.
But he never got the chance.
JSTOR noticed the huge spike in downloads
and alerted MIT, which launched an investigation
alongside the Cambridge Police Department
and the U.S. Secret Service.
Blocking the IP address from which the requests
originated didn’t work; the person responsible
simply switched IPs to continue the mass downloading.
A second computer then connected to MIT’s
network.
Both laptops downloaded articles at such a
staggering rate that several of JSTOR’s
servers crashed.
JSTOR then blocked access to all MIT users
for several days.
On January 4, 2011, authorities discovered
a laptop hidden in the utility closet in Building
16.
They decided to leave the laptop in place
to see if the person who put it there would
return.
They also installed a hidden camera in the
closet to identify the intruder.
30 minutes later, Aaron is captured on video
entering the closet to purportedly replace
the hard drive.
The video you’re watching was originally
published by Wired.com, which obtained it
through a Freedom of Information Act lawsuit
against the U.S. Secret Service.
Two days later, on January 6, 2011, someone
entered the closet again, covering their face
with a bike helmet.
They removed the laptop and hard drive and
left.
The MIT police weren’t able to reach the
closet in time to apprehend the person.
But the suspect didn’t leave the campus
immediately.
The same laptop then connected to MIT’s
Student Center.
Perhaps to access the network from a different
location to avoid detection.
Later that afternoon, an MIT police officer
who saw the surveillance footage recognized
the same guy riding his bike on campus.
When the officer approached Aaron, Aaron leaped
off his bike and ran away.
But MIT police and a secret service agent
caught up with him and arrested him for breaking
and entering.
At the time of his arrest, Aaron was found
to possess a USB drive containing the program
“keepgrabbing.py” - the same software
program found on the laptop in the closet.
There was no doubt they had the right person.
The U.S. Attorney’s Office in Boston charged
Aaron with numerous counts of wire fraud and
violating the Computer Fraud and Abuse act.
The charges carried a maximum sentence of
35 years in prison and a fine of up to $1
million.
His supporters called it ludicrous; they argued
he simply wanted to make academic research
more widely available.
They believed the punishment didn’t fit
the crime.
However, Carmen Ortiz, the then U.S. Attorney
for the District of Massachusetts who oversaw
Aaron’s prosecution, argued:
“Stealing is stealing, whether you use a
computer command or a crowbar, and whether
you take documents, data or dollars.”
JSTOR chose NOT to press charges after Aaron
turned over his hard drives.
The prosecution offered Aaron a plea deal.
Had he accepted it, he would have gone to
prison for only six months.
His girlfriend Taren reflected on the difficult
decision he had to make.
The whole thing was so hard and so stressful.
And he felt - he carried so much of the weight
of it on his own.
He didn’t want to involve his friends.
He wanted to protect people but he wasn’t
very good at protecting himself.
Aaron refused the plea bargain because he
didn’t want to be labeled a felon.
A close friend and former girlfriend recalled
to Rolling Stone how they were standing outside
the White House one day when Aaron turned
to her and said, “‘You know, they don’t
allow felons to work there.'”
At the time he was charged, he had been a
research fellow at Harvard.
Harvard then suspended his fellowship and
banned him from campus.
Aaron settled into a studio apartment in Brooklyn,
awaiting trial.
He grew increasingly isolated and depressed.
He had struggled for years with depression,
often triggered by his stomach issues.
Long before the JSTOR incident, he wrote a
blog on his personal website that described
his state of mind:
“Go outside and get some fresh air or cuddle
with a loved one and you don’t feel any
better, only more upset at being unable to
feel the joy that everyone else seems to feel.
Everything gets colored by the sadness.”
“You feel as if streaks of pain are running
through your head, you thrash your body, you
search for some escape but find none.”
On January 11, 2013, Aaron Swartz was found
dead in his apartment in New York City.
He was 26 years old.
I think he woke up two years after this ordeal
started, and I think he couldn’t face another
day of the stress, the uncertainty, the lack
of control over his own destiny.
Aaron’s partner and family blamed his death
on prosecutors, declaring in a statement:
“Aaron’s death is not simply a personal
tragedy.
It is the product of a criminal justice system
rife with intimidation and prosecutorial overreach.
Decisions made by officials in the Massachusetts
U.S. Attorney’s Office and at MIT contributed
to his death.”
There were calls for U.S. Attorney Carmen
Ortiz to be removed.
She defended her handling of the case this
way:
“...this office sought an appropriate sentence
that matched the alleged conduct – a sentence
that we would recommend to the judge of six
months in a low security setting.
While at the same time, his defense counsel
would have been free to recommend a sentence
of probation.
Ultimately, any sentence imposed would have
been up to the judge.
At no time did this office ever seek – or
ever tell Mr. Swartz’s attorneys that it
intended to seek – maximum penalties under
the law.”
Aaron leaves a lasting legacy.
He was an early contributor to the development
of the Creative Commons license, which provides
a legal framework for creators to share their
work with others under certain conditions.
It has since become an important tool for
promoting open access to information – his
goal all along.
I have personally benefited from the use of
creative commons.
If I couldn’t access this vast library of
free and open content, I would have had to
spend much more time sourcing material, making
videos like this one much more difficult to
produce.
Aaron’s belief in limiting the power of
institutions has influenced debates on free
speech and whether social media companies
have gone too far in censoring information.
He had co-founded an advocacy group dedicated
to protecting civil liberties and fighting
censorship.
People often ask me, what’s going to happen?
And the answer is: it’s up to you.
You get to decide what will happen.
This isn’t something playing out on a stage
somewhere where big giants fight each other,
and you get to sit and munch popcorn.
This is a fight you can join in.
It’s up to you.
The case against Aaron wasn’t the first
of its kind to challenge online civil disobedience.
The same year of Aaron’s death, Ross Ulbricht
was arrested and charged with running the
dark web online marketplace Silk Road.
The harsh sentence Ross received has been
the topic of widespread discussion.
You can check out my video on that, which
I’ve linked in my description.
The computer science skills of Aaron Swartz
and Ross Ulbricht played a huge role in their
attempt to change the world.
Although their actions led to legal consequences,
their stories demonstrate the power that STEM
can have to make an impact.
Well, Brilliant.org is a website and app where
you can learn science, computer science, and
math interactively.
My viewers especially love their computer
science courses.
They’re great whether you’re starting
out or if you want to brush up on your skills.
You can dive deeper into more advanced topics
as you progress through their lessons.
Brilliant supports you every step of the way.
If you’re stuck, you can view the explanation
to see where you went wrong.
There are thousands of lessons to choose from,
everything from foundational and advanced
math to data science.
I personally use Brilliant to go through their
logic puzzles to improve my analytical thinking.
Brilliant is FREE for you to try out for 30
days if you head to my custom link in my description:
brilliant.org/newsthink.
And the first 200 people who sign up with
my link will get 20% off their annual subscription.
Thanks for watching, I’m Cindy Pom.